Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. He kept the Marxist books in his room, took them to the library for renewal, carried them back home. The books themselves were secret, forbidden and hard to read. They altered the room, charged it with meaning. The drabness of his surroundings, his own shabby clothes, were explained and transformed by these books. He saw himself as part of something vast and sweeping. He was the product of a sweeping history. He and his mother locked into a process, a system of money and property that diminished
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。他把马克思主义书籍藏在房间里，带去图书馆续借，又带回家。这些书本身是秘密的、被禁的，而且很难读。它们改变了这个房间，赋予了它某种意义。他周围环境的沉闷、他自己破旧的衣服，都因为这些书而得到了解释和升华。他觉得自己是某种宏大而深远事物的一部分。他是宏大历史的产物。他和他的母亲被锁在了一个金钱和财产的体系中，这个体系每天都在削弱
their human worth every day, as if by scientific law. The books made him part of something. Something led up to his presence in this room, in this particular skin, and something would follow." So that, Dominic, is Don DeLillo, the great American novelist, writing about Lee Harvey Oswald in his tremendous novel Libra, which he published in 1988. And it's actually a while since I read it. But as I recall, the conspiracy theory in that it's a kind of an alliance of the CIA and Cuban exiles. That's right. They've created a plot because it's a book not just about the Kennedy assassination, but it's about plotting and narrative, isn't it? It is. And it's kind of about the unknowability, isn't it? Because essentially,
他们的人格价值，仿佛遵循着某种科学定律。这些书让他成为了某种事物的一部分。某种东西促成了他出现在这个房间里，出现在这具躯壳中，而某种东西也将随之而来。”多米尼克，这就是伟大的美国小说家唐·德里罗（Don DeLillo）在 1988 年出版的巨著《天秤座》（Libra）中，关于李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德（Lee Harvey Oswald）的描写。其实我已经很久没读这本书了。但据我回忆，书中的阴谋论是一种中央情报局（CIA）与古巴流亡者结盟的说法。没错。他们策划了一个阴谋，因为这本书不仅是关于肯尼迪遇刺案，更是关于策划和叙事，不是吗？确实如此。而且它某种程度上是关于“不可知性”，对吧？因为从本质上讲，
Don DeLillo, who's a brilliantly sophisticated novelist and very aware of the porous borders between fiction and nonfiction, is essentially casting the Warren Commission as another work of fiction. Yeah. So the assassination almost begins as a work of fiction that then comes true, doesn't it? The CIA create their conspiracy, they implot it, and then they cast Oswald. It becomes true, and then the Warren Commission itself is a kind of narrative. So a little bit like Foucault's Pendulum, Umberto Eco's novel, where a conspiracy theory is constructed and then the conspirators find it's actually true. Exactly. And you can see why novelists have always been fascinated. James Elroy,
唐·德里罗是一位极其老练的小说家，非常清楚虚构与非虚构之间那层多孔的界限，他本质上是将沃伦委员会（Warren Commission）视为另一部虚构作品。是的。所以这场暗杀几乎是以一部虚构作品的形式开始，然后变成了现实，不是吗？中情局制造了他们的阴谋，将其编织成情节，然后选定了奥斯瓦尔德。它变成了现实，而沃伦委员会本身也成了一种叙事。这有点像翁贝托·埃科（Umberto Eco）的小说《傅科摆》（Foucault's Pendulum），其中一个阴谋论被构建出来，然后阴谋家们发现它竟然是真的。完全正确。你可以看出为什么小说家们一直对此着迷。詹姆斯·艾尔罗伊（James Ellroy），
you mentioned in the last episode, Norman Mailer, have been fascinated by the Kennedys and the Kennedy assassination. Because if you're interested in narrative, in plotting, as you say, in the relationship between fact and fiction, this is a gift to you as a writer, isn't it? Absolutely. But Don DeLillo places Lee Harvey Oswald, despite all the wrapping of conspiracy and so on, he places Lee Harvey Oswald at the center of the story, rather than the way that actually the Warren Commission does. I mean, the Warren Commission says Lee Harvey Oswald did it, and he acted alone, and there was no conspiracy, and Lee Harvey Oswald did not know Jack Ruby, and Jack Ruby likewise was not part of a conspiracy. And we are now, we've done six
你在上一集提到的诺曼·梅勒（Norman Mailer），都对肯尼迪家族和肯尼迪遇刺案着迷。因为如果你对叙事、对情节，正如你所说，对事实与虚构之间的关系感兴趣，这对于作家来说简直是天赐之物，不是吗？绝对是。但唐·德里罗将李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德置于故事的中心，尽管有各种阴谋论的包装等等，他这样做与沃伦委员会的做法不同。我的意思是，沃伦委员会说李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德干的，他单独行动，没有阴谋，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德不认识杰克·鲁比（Jack Ruby），杰克·鲁比同样不是阴谋的一部分。我们现在已经做了六
episodes. I want to know what you think. And I'm guessing from pretty much everything that you said beforehand, that you would agree with the Warren Commission, which is great news for the Warren Commission to say. It validates them. What a wonderful endorsement for them. So I think the keys to this crime are in the personality of the victim and of the killer. So we spent a lot of time talking about John F. Kennedy because I think understanding his personalities was so important to understanding why it's, to me, inherently implausible that powerful government agencies would wish to murder him in broad daylight. Because I think understanding the essential kind of small C conservatism of Kennedy, his involvement in the Second World War,
集了。我想知道你的想法。根据你之前所说的一切，我猜你会同意沃伦委员会的结论，这对沃伦委员会来说是个好消息。这验证了他们的结论。对他们来说真是极好的背书。所以我认为这起罪行的关键在于受害者和凶手的性格。我们花了很多时间谈论约翰·F·肯尼迪，因为我认为理解他的性格对于理解为什么我认为强大的政府机构想要在光天化日之下谋杀他，在本质上是不可信的，这一点非常重要。因为我认为理解肯尼迪那种本质上的“小写c”保守主义，他参与第二次世界大战的经历，
his devotion to America, his devotion to America's role in the world, when you understand all that, and you understand what kind of president he was, I think that allows you to eliminate some of these suspects, because it's obvious they would not have any meaningful motive. But now we come to the man who was seen walking away from the Texas Book Depository and was later involved in shooting the police from J.D. Tippett. And I think if we understand Lee Harvey Oswald, Tom, we will understand this crime and we will have the answer to the mystery. So you think that Captain Fritz, the man who interrogated him, and who in a sense, I suppose, has a better understanding of what might have motivated him, and who says that he definitely did it. You agree with him that it is Lee Harvey Oswald? I do, Tom. I do
他对美国的忠诚，他对美国在世界中所扮演角色的忠诚，当你理解了这一切，理解了他是什么样的总统，我认为这让你能够排除掉其中一些嫌疑人，因为很明显他们没有任何实质性的动机。但现在我们谈到那个被看到从德克萨斯州教科书仓库大楼走出来，后来又参与枪杀警察J.D.蒂皮特（J.D. Tippit）的人。我认为如果我们理解了李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，汤姆，我们就会理解这起罪行，并找到这个谜团的答案。所以你认为审讯他的弗里茨（Fritz）队长，在某种意义上，我认为他比别人更了解是什么激励了他，而且他说确实是奥斯瓦尔德干的。你同意他的观点，即凶手就是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德吗？我同意，汤姆。我确实
think Lee Harvey Oswald killed John F. Kennedy. And I think when we go into his life and we discuss his movements, it will become clear why he is such a plausible suspect. And then when we list some of the evidence, you will see that no other explanation carries so much evidentiary weight. But let's start with Oswald himself. Oswald was born in New Orleans, Louisiana, September 1939, the outbreak of the Second World War in Europe. And he is born to Robert Oswald and Margaret Clavery. It's his mother's second marriage. His father, Robert, died of a heart attack two months before he was born. He is born to a single mother. His mother is a very,
认为李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德杀害了约翰·F·肯尼迪。而且我认为当我们深入研究他的生活并讨论他的行踪时，就会清楚为什么他是一个如此可信的嫌疑人。当我们列举一些证据时，你会发现没有其他解释具有如此大的证据权重。但让我们从奥斯瓦尔德本人开始。奥斯瓦尔德于 1939 年 9 月出生在路易斯安那州的新奥尔良，当时欧洲爆发了第二次世界大战。他是罗伯特·奥斯瓦尔德（Robert Oswald）和玛格丽特·克拉弗里（Marguerite Claverie）的孩子。这是他母亲的第二次婚姻。他的父亲罗伯特在他出生前两个月死于心脏病。他是一个单亲母亲的孩子。他的母亲是一个非常、
very rackety person. She ends up moving to Dallas and he goes to school in Fort Worth initially. He is a shy, withdrawn, difficult boy, troubled boy. And this is completely understandable because his mother has married for a third time a guy called Erwin Ekdal, and she has a very tempestuous relationship with this guy Ekdal. She is a very troubled woman herself, Marguerite. And Lee, you know, like so many children, so many towns across the world,
非常古怪的人。她最终搬到了达拉斯，而他最初在沃斯堡上学。他是一个害羞、孤僻、难以相处、令人烦恼的男孩。这完全可以理解，因为他的母亲第三次嫁给了一个叫欧文·埃克达尔（Erwin Ekdal）的家伙，她和这个埃克达尔的关系非常动荡。她自己，玛格丽特，也是一个非常令人烦恼的女人。而李，你知道，就像世界上许多城镇里的许多孩子一样，
he is affected by that. And the reports of him that we have at school when he's a little boy are that he is a sullen little boy. He's aggressive. He likes reading. I mean, the reading is... We started with books, Tom. And I think the books are important. I think they're really important, actually. People tend to underestimate the importance of his Marxism and his politics. So his mother, you said that she's a difficult woman, but one of the keys to her character, it seems, is that she feels that her life has not measured up to her expectation of what it should have been. Do you think that Lee Harvey Oswald has that same sense, a sense of his own talents and the fact that his circumstances are not adequate to those talents? Undoubtedly. Undoubtedly, Tom. So already we have a couple of things that a lot of assassins have in common. So your John Hinckley's, your Arthur Bremer's, the people who have tried to shoot public figures in American history. It is very common that they will
他受到了影响。我们得到的关于他小时候在学校的报告说，他是一个阴郁的小男孩。他很有攻击性。他喜欢阅读。我的意思是，阅读是……我们从书本开始谈起的，汤姆。我认为书本很重要。实际上，我认为它们非常重要。人们往往低估了他的马克思主义和政治观点的重要性。所以他的母亲，你说她是一个难以相处的女人，但她性格的关键似乎在于，她觉得自己的生活没有达到她预期的样子。你认为李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德也有同样的感觉吗？一种对自己才华的认知，以及他的处境配不上这些才华的事实？毫无疑问。毫无疑问，汤姆。所以我们已经有了很多刺客共同的几点特征。比如约翰·欣克利（John Hinckley）、亚瑟·布雷默（Arthur Bremer），那些试图在美利坚历史上枪击公众人物的人。他们非常普遍地会
be boys who have had troubled childhoods, who have had very difficult relationships with their parents, who have been lonely, withdrawn, sullen, but who also have been dreamers. In the same way that somebody like Adolf Hitler was a dreamer. I mean, if you want to take a much more benevolent, we've mentioned this comparison many times between Hitler and Churchill. Churchill was also, of course, a dreamer. Boys tend to be dreamers. I mean, Churchill's life did measure up to his dreams.
是那些童年不幸、与父母关系非常紧张、孤独、孤僻、阴郁，但同时又是梦想家的男孩。就像阿道夫·希特勒（Adolf Hitler）那样的人是一个梦想家。我的意思是，如果你想做一个更仁慈的比较，我们多次提到希特勒和丘吉尔（Churchill）之间的比较。丘吉尔当然也是一个梦想家。男孩往往是梦想家。我的意思是，丘吉尔的生活确实符合了他的梦想。
Hitler made his dreams a reality. Assassins are often boys who continue to have these dreams, but they are constantly disappointed. Fate and life is against them. The odds are against them from the start, and they react to that by being bitter and resentful. And that's definitely the case with Lee. And so in a sense, they become conspiracy theorists because they come to feel that life, some malevolent force, whether it's supernatural or not, is acting against them.
希特勒把他的梦想变成了现实。刺客往往是那些继续怀揣这些梦想，但却不断感到失望的男孩。命运和生活从一开始就与他们作对，他们通过变得愤世嫉俗和怨恨来做出反应。李的情况绝对就是这样。所以从某种意义上说，他们变成了阴谋论者，因为他们开始觉得生活，某种邪恶的力量，无论是超自然的还是其他的，都在与他们作对。
Undoubtedly, Tom. Undoubtedly. Lee moves to New York when he's 12 with his mother. She's moving around, so it's a very unstable life they lead. Don DeLillo's book that you quoted from at the beginning, that begins with him in New York riding the subway trains, overwhelmed by the light and the darkness and the kind of sensory overload of being in New York in the 1950s. Lee goes to school in the Bronx. He plays truant from school. He is at this point identified as a very difficult
毫无疑问，汤姆。毫无疑问。李 12 岁时随母亲搬到了纽约。她一直在搬家，所以他们过着非常不稳定的生活。你开头引用的唐·德里罗的书，开头写他在纽约乘坐地铁，被 20 世纪 50 年代纽约的光影和那种感官过载所淹没。李在布朗克斯上学。他逃学。此时他被认定为一个非常难以相处
and troubled boy. He's sent to a reformatory for psychiatric assessment. And we have a report on him from a caseworker at Columbia University. She says he's detached, he's withdrawn. She quite likes him. She says there's a rather pleasant, appealing quality about this emotionally starved, affectionless youngster, which grows as one speaks to him and it seems clear that he's detached himself from the world around him because no one in it ever met any of his needs for love you know his mother is totally self-absorbed crazy affairs and relationships very difficult and she doesn't take any interest in lee do we also have the report of the psychiatrist from the reformatory, Dr. Hartogs, a tense and withdrawn and evasive boy.
和令人烦恼的男孩。他被送往感化院进行精神评估。我们有一份来自哥伦比亚大学个案工作者的关于他的报告。她说他很疏离，很孤僻。她其实挺喜欢他。她说，在这个情感匮乏、缺乏关爱的年轻人身上，有一种相当令人愉悦、吸引人的特质，当你与他交谈时，这种特质会愈发明显，而且很明显，他之所以将自己与周围的世界隔绝开来，是因为世界上的任何人都没有满足过他对爱的需求。你知道，他的母亲完全沉浸在自我中，疯狂的恋情和关系，非常麻烦，她对李一点也不关心。我们还有感化院精神科医生哈托格斯（Hartogs）博士的报告，一个紧张、孤僻、闪烁其词的男孩。
He likes to give the impression he didn't care about others. Difficult to penetrate the emotional wall behind which this boy hides, his feelings of awkwardness and insecurity. He diagnoses him as having personality pattern disturbance with schizoid features and passive-aggressive tendencies.
他喜欢给人留下他不关心别人的印象。很难穿透这个男孩隐藏情感的心理防线，他感到尴尬和不安全。他诊断他患有具有分裂样特征和被动攻击倾向的人格模式障碍。
The reason I say all this is do you remember captain fritz's interrogation of oswald and the reaction of all the dallas pd who said they found oswald oddly sometimes detached robotic like he wasn't really there this is precisely the description that is given by these people when um lee harvey oswald is in his mid-teens in New York. I mean, it's uncanny how similar they are. He still has problems at school in 1953. There's talk of him being put into a home away from his mother. So she's that bad a parent?
我之所以说这些，是因为你还记得弗里茨队长对奥斯瓦尔德的审讯，以及所有达拉斯警察局人员的反应吗？他们说他们发现奥斯瓦尔德有时显得奇怪地疏离、像机器人一样，好像他根本不在那里。这正是当李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德十几岁在纽约时，这些人对他的描述。我的意思是，他们如此相似，真是不可思议。1953 年他在学校仍然有问题。有人谈论把他送到一个远离他母亲的寄宿家庭。所以她是一个那么糟糕的母亲吗？
That bad a parent, exactly. Let's not underestimate how bad. This isn't just that he's from a poor family or a single parent family or one in which his mother has a complicated love life. She's a sufficiently bad parent. Well, because the weird thing that is often said about her when her son is in police custody, that she seems almost to be enjoying it. At last, she's a center of attention. At last, she's not a nobody. Yes, exactly.
就是那么糟糕的母亲，没错。让我们不要低估到底有多糟糕。这不仅仅是因为他来自一个贫困家庭或单亲家庭，或者一个母亲有复杂感情生活的家庭。她是一个足够糟糕的母亲。嗯，因为当她的儿子被警方拘留时，人们常说的一件奇怪的事情是，她似乎几乎在享受这一切。终于，她是关注的焦点了。终于，她不是一个无名小卒了。是的，没错。
And you can see how if his mother thinks like that, that Lee himself, the fear of being a nobody, the sense that we all have come across people like this or heard of people like this, people who feel life has not treated them properly. And it is a conspiracy. The high-ups, the rich, teachers, social workers, they're all in it. He becomes a socialist very early on and then in due course, a Marxist. Yes. I mean, I don't want to engage in cold psychology, but I'm going to engage in cod psychology.
你可以看出，如果他的母亲那样想，那么李本人，对成为无名小卒的恐惧，那种我们都遇到过或听说过这样的人的感觉，那些觉得生活没有公平对待他们的人。这是一个阴谋。高层、富人、老师、社会工作者，他们都在其中。他很早就成为了社会主义者，随后顺理成章地成为了马克思主义者。是的。我的意思是，我不想进行庸俗心理学分析，但我还是要进行庸俗心理学分析。
We love it. As living in New York, the great engine room of capitalism, this great giddy, gilded, golden city full of wealth and power, do you think the sense of being alienated from that is what is feeding into his, what ultimately comes to seem a hatred for capitalism, but more specifically for America itself. Undoubtedly. He definitely becomes a socialist or identifies himself as a socialist by 16, 17. He writes to the Socialist Party of America. So we have a letter in which he says he's been studying socialist principles for well over 15 months. Lee is not an immensely bright boy. I mean, he is a reader and he's interested in ideas, but he's not Ludwig Wittgenstein. He's an autodidact and he stumbles across
我们喜欢这样。作为生活在纽约这个资本主义大引擎室里的人，这个充满财富和权力的令人眩晕、镀金、金色的城市，你认为那种与此疏离的感觉是否正在助长他最终表现出来的对资本主义，更具体地说是对美国本身的仇恨？毫无疑问。到 16、17 岁时，他绝对已经成为了社会主义者或自认为是社会主义者。他写信给美国社会党。所以我们有一封信，他在信中说他研究社会主义原则已经超过 15 个月了。李不是一个极其聪明的男孩。我的意思是，他是一个读者，他对思想感兴趣，但他不是路德维希·维特根斯坦（Ludwig Wittgenstein）。他是一个自学者，他偶然发现了
socialism and Marxism and it gives him the answers. And a dignity as well, right? Because if he's the alienated proletariat, then he's destined to inherit the world. Undoubtedly. I mean, if it hadn't been Marxism, it might well have been something else, a religion of some kind and a militant version of some religion or some other political creed. If he'd been in Germany in the 1920s, it could have been communism, could have been Nazism, that kind of thing. I think Marxism, the interesting thing about Marxism is that Marxism, like so many militant creeds, you could argue is itself a conspiracy
社会主义和马克思主义，这给了他答案。还有尊严，对吧？因为如果他是被疏离的无产阶级，那么他注定要继承这个世界。毫无疑问。我的意思是，如果不是马克思主义，很可能是其他东西，某种宗教，某种激进的宗教版本或其他政治信条。如果他在 20 世纪 20 年代的德国，那可能是共产主义，也可能是纳粹主义，诸如此类。我认为马克思主义，关于马克思主义有趣的一点是，马克思主义，像许多激进的信条一样，你也可以说它本身就是一个阴谋
theory, right? That there are the good guys and the bad guys. There are, yeah. That this will explain the workings. And also that you have a duty to, Marx never puts it like this, but it's very evident in his writings, you have a moral duty to overthrow the evil. I mean, that's why I think that reading that you began with, the Dalila reading, is so suggestive. The books that he reads gives him the sense that he is part of something meaningful, a sweeping history. He has his part to play. He has his dignity. Right, because by dissolving his agency as an individual, it gives becomes a US Marine. Why a US Marine if you're a Marxist? Well, you can kind of see why, can't you? It gives him a sense of belonging.
论，对吧？有好人和坏人。确实，是的。这可以解释其运作方式。而且你还有义务，马克思从未这样说过，但这在他的著作中非常明显，你有道德义务去推翻邪恶。我的意思是，这就是为什么我认为你开头读的那段德里罗的文字如此具有启发性。他读的书让他觉得他是某种有意义的事物的一部分，一段宏大的历史。他有自己的角色要扮演。他有自己的尊严。没错，因为通过消解他作为个人的主体性，它给了他……他成为了美国海军陆战队员。如果你是马克思主义者，为什么要加入美国海军陆战队？嗯，你可以看出原因，不是吗？这给了他一种归属感。
It doesn't quite fit with his Marxism, but he will see the world. He goes to Mississippi. He's in California. He's in Japan. He's in the Philippines. And Dominic, in the Marines, is he trained to shoot? Well, you're asking because you know the answer to that. Of course he is.
这与他的马克思主义不太吻合，但他会看到世界。他去了密西西比州。他在加利福尼亚。他在日本。他在菲律宾。多米尼克，在海军陆战队，他接受过射击训练吗？嗯，你问是因为你知道答案。当然有。
Of course he is. Of course he is. Now, it is so often said that Lee Harvey Oswald could not have shot John F. Kennedy because he was not a good shot. And this is just wrong. He was a good shot. In December 1956, he did a test and he scored 212.
当然有。当然有。现在，人们经常说李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德不可能射杀约翰·F·肯尼迪，因为他不是一个好射手。这完全是错误的。他是一个好射手。1956 年 12 月，他参加了一次测试，得了 212 分。
I don't actually know what that's out of or what it means, but apparently this is a good enough score to qualify you as a sharpshooter. Three years later, he does, well, two and a half years later, May 1959, he does another test. He scores worse.
我其实不知道这是满分多少，或者这意味着什么，但显然这是一个足以让你获得神枪手资格的好分数。三年后，他，嗯，两年半后，1959 年 5 月，他参加了另一次测试。他得分更低。
He scores 191, and that means he's no longer rated sharpshooter. He's rated as marksman. But by that point, actually, he's already lost interest in the Marines, and he's getting ready to leave. So some people say, is he really trying anymore? Either way, he's already lost interest in the marines and he's getting ready to leave so some people say is he that is he really trying anymore either way he's a better shooter than tom dick and harry on
他得了 191 分，这意味着他不再被评为神枪手。他被评为射手。但到那时，其实他已经对海军陆战队失去了兴趣，准备离开了。所以有些人说，他真的还在努力吗？无论如何，他已经对海军陆战队失去了兴趣，准备离开了，所以有些人说，他真的还在努力吗？无论如何，他比街上的汤姆、迪克和哈里
the street yeah the three hobos right three hobos exactly man he's a better shooter than jack ruby i mean jack ruby's shot oswald from a distance of about two inches um oswald you know he can do this. At this point, he's fixated weirdly on Russia. So we know that he used to read a Russian dictionary, that he would study Russian. And it's sometimes said, well, the CIA put him up to this. I mean, he was an unusual figure because they didn't normally get Marines to read Russian. So he must have been singled out as an agent. Actually, we know that his fellow marines thought it was amusing. Red Lee. Yeah. They would say Red Lee. It made him a character. It's a bit like if you were a royal marine today, well, and you were reading Russian. The other marines, they wouldn't say, my God,
都要射得准。是的，三个流浪汉，对吧？三个流浪汉，没错，伙计，他比杰克·鲁比射得准。我的意思是，杰克·鲁比在两英寸的距离外射杀了奥斯瓦尔德，嗯，奥斯瓦尔德，你知道，他能做到这一点。此时，他奇怪地迷恋着俄罗斯。所以我们知道他过去常读俄语词典，他会学习俄语。有时人们会说，中情局让他这么做的。我的意思是，他是一个不寻常的人物，因为他们通常不会让海军陆战队员读俄语。所以他一定是被选定为特工。事实上，我们知道他的海军陆战队战友觉得这很有趣。“红色李”（Red Lee）。是的。他们会叫他“红色李”。这让他成了一个有个性的人。这有点像如果你今天是一名皇家海军陆战队员，嗯，你在读俄语。其他海军陆战队员，他们不会说，天哪，
the man must be a traitor and an agent. They would probably think it was a funny quirk, like a joke. Something distinctive. Something distinctive, a bit wacky. And that's how they think of Lee Harvey Oswald. He goes around saying, you know, I'm a communist, I'm a Marxist. He's insubordinate sometimes to his superiors. He will, you know, we've talked so many times in the rest of his history about Ronald Reagan and his love of the Reader's Digest.
这个人一定是个叛徒和特工。他们可能会觉得这只是一个有趣的怪癖，像个笑话。某种独特的东西。某种独特的东西，有点古怪。这就是他们看待李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的方式。他到处说，你知道，我是个共产主义者，我是个马克思主义者。他有时对上级不服从。他会，你知道，我们在《历史的余味》中谈论过很多次罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan）和他对《读者文摘》（Reader's Digest）的热爱。
Lee Harvey Oswald is reading similar periodicals, but from more sort of extreme periodicals, from a left-wing perspective. He'll read some nonsense about China, and then he'll be asking his superiors about it. They don't know anything about it. Difficult questions about tractor production in Changi or whatever. Exactly. And then he'll sort of smirk to himself that he knows more than they do. That must have made him popular with his commanding officers. Exactly. He's very unpopular because he doesn't shine his shoes.
李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德也在读类似的期刊，但从更极端的左翼视角来看。他会读一些关于中国的胡言乱语，然后他会问他的上级关于这些的问题。他们对此一无所知。关于昌吉拖拉机生产之类的棘手问题。没错。然后他会暗自窃笑，觉得自己比他们知道得多。这一定让他很受指挥官欢迎。没错。他非常不受欢迎，因为他不擦鞋。
He gets up late. He wears his hat too low so that he doesn't have to look his officers in the eye. And he's generally... It's all very teenage behaviour. He's very teen. Well, I mean, how old is he at this point? 20. He's a very young man who is behaving as young men sometimes do.
他起得很晚。他把帽子压得很低，这样就不必直视长官的眼睛。他通常……这都是非常青少年的行为。他非常孩子气。嗯，我的意思是，他此时多大？20岁。他是一个非常年轻的人，表现得像年轻人有时会做的那样。
That summer, 1959, he asks if he can leave the Marines because he says his mother is ill, she isn't, and he's discharged. And he has dreamed up this scheme of going to the Soviet Union. Just a mad thing to do, but a sign of what an eccentric, troubled... Because this is the teeth of the Cold War. I mean, we've got the Berlin Walls being built and the Cuban Missile Crisis is hoving into view and he's off to the Soviet Union.
那个夏天，1959 年，他请求离开海军陆战队，因为他说他母亲病了，其实并没有，然后他退伍了。他构想了这个去苏联的计划。这简直是疯狂的行为，但这是一个迹象，表明他是一个多么古怪、令人烦恼的人……因为这正处于冷战的白热化时期。我的意思是，柏林墙正在修建，古巴导弹危机即将来临，而他却要去苏联。
But this is his chance to become a somebody, isn't it, Tom? To do something, have an adventure. But just to say, I mean, this is really very, very odd. And so you can see why this has served to germinate all kinds of conspiracy theories. Of course. Because it is very, very unusual. But again, I suppose you could stand it on its head and say, it's the fact that he's such an unusual person that explains why he ends up doing such an unusual
但这对他来说是成为“某个人”的机会，不是吗，汤姆？去做点什么，去冒险。但只是想说，我的意思是，这真的非常、非常奇怪。所以你可以看出为什么这助长了各种阴谋论。当然。因为它非常、非常不寻常。但同样，我想你可以把它反过来看，说正是因为他是一个如此不寻常的人，才解释了为什么他最终会做出如此不寻常
and horrific crime. I think that's right, Tom. He gets a ship to France, then he travels via London and Switzerland to Helsinki, and then he takes a train to Moscow. And when he arrives in Moscow on 16th of October, 1959... And just to ask, you can just turn up, can you, if you're an American? Because it seems improbable. Do you need a visa? I mean, how does it work? Well, this is the thing. He gets on the train, and the train from Helsinki arrives. This is the age of Finlandization. So Finland is kind of in a weird grey area halfway between the West and the East. So it's appeasing both sides. So Finland is this kind of in a weird grey area halfway between the west and the east.
和可怕的罪行。我认为那是对的，汤姆。他乘船去法国，然后经由伦敦和瑞士前往赫尔辛基，然后乘火车去莫斯科。当他于 1959 年 10 月 16 日抵达莫斯科时……顺便问一下，如果你是美国人，你可以直接出现吗？因为这似乎不太可能。你需要签证吗？我的意思是，它是怎么运作的？嗯，这就是问题所在。他上了火车，从赫尔辛基来的火车抵达了。这是“芬兰化”的时代。所以芬兰处于西方和东方之间一个奇怪的灰色地带。所以它在安抚双方。所以芬兰处于西方和东方之间一个奇怪的灰色地带。
So it's appeasing both sides. So Finland is this kind of grey zone. And you can literally get on a train. And you don't need a visa at all. Well, if you haven't got a visa, you'll be thrown out. But why would they allow a US Marine in? I genuinely don't understand that. Well, they don't know he's coming.
所以它在安抚双方。所以芬兰是这种灰色地带。你真的可以上火车。而且你根本不需要签证。嗯，如果你没有签证，你会被赶出去。但他们为什么要让一个美国海军陆战队员进来？我真的不明白。嗯，他们不知道他要来。
I mean, they haven't been told he's coming. He turns up and they're absolutely astounded. So he is in touch with Intourist, which is the tourist board. Basically, everything has to be done when you go to the communist bloc through the state-approved tourist boards. He arrives in Moscow and he says to the tourist people, I want to become a Soviet citizen. And they don't know what to do with him. They're completely baffled. This does not happen all the time. He's not saying he's being persecuted in America or anything? He says he doesn't like America and and he wants to become russian and they i mean he obviously hasn't been
我的意思是，没人告诉他们他要来。他出现了，他们完全惊呆了。所以他联系了“国际旅行社”（Intourist），也就是旅游局。基本上，当你去共产主义集团时，一切都必须通过国家批准的旅游局来完成。他抵达莫斯科，对旅游局的人说，我想成为苏联公民。他们不知道该拿他怎么办。他们完全困惑了。这种情况不会一直发生。他不是说他在美国受到迫害什么的吗？他说他不喜欢美国，他想成为俄罗斯人，而他们，我的意思是，他显然没有受到
persecuted tom so he can't claim asylum realistically and actually the soviet and kgb officials are just utterly bewildered by him the kgb ask the obvious question is he a spy they think well he can't be a spy because cia spies don't get a train and pitch up and say, I'd like to become Russian. It's too obvious. Maybe it's a cunning double bluff. So actually, five days after he's arrived, they say to him, listen, you know, you can't stay. Completely understandably and reasonably, because they think this is weird. This doesn't happen.
迫害，汤姆，所以他不能现实地申请庇护，而且实际上，苏联和克格勃官员对他完全感到困惑。克格勃问了一个显而易见的问题：他是间谍吗？他们想，嗯，他不可能是一个间谍，因为中情局间谍不会坐火车过来，然后说，我想成为俄罗斯人。这太明显了。也许这是一个狡猾的双重虚张声势。所以实际上，在他抵达五天后，他们对他说，听着，你知道，你不能留下来。完全可以理解且合理，因为他们认为这很奇怪。这种情况不会发生。
This is kind of against the rules. So what he does is he tries to kill himself in his hotel. He cuts his wrist. They take him to a hospital. They send him to a psychiatric hospital. And they say, well, all right. Well, they basically say, you can stay while we have a think, while we think what to do.
这有点违反规则。所以他做的是在酒店里试图自杀。他割了手腕。他们把他送到医院。他们把他送到精神病院。他们说，好吧。嗯，他们基本上说，在我们考虑的时候，在我们想好该怎么办的时候，你可以留下来。
While they're thinking what to do, he goes to the US embassy and he says, I would like to give up my American citizenship. And soon afterwards, a little story appeared in the American press. Mad man goes to Russia, basically, and says he no longer wants to be America. But it's not a big story. Nobody in America really thinks that much of it. It's just he's a wacky, eccentric person who has done something very eccentric. The Soviet authorities eventually decide, well, okay, he can't be a spy because
在他们考虑该怎么办的时候，他去了美国大使馆，说，我想放弃我的美国国籍。不久之后，美国媒体上出现了一篇小报道。疯子去了俄罗斯，基本上说他不想再做美国人了。但这并不是什么大新闻。美国没人真的太在意。他只是一个古怪、离经叛道的人，做了一件非常古怪的事情。苏联当局最终决定，嗯，好吧，他不可能是一个间谍，因为
he's such an incompetent, inept person. The CIA would never employ such a person. I mean, this is KGB when the archives were open in the 1990s. They said, we looked into Oswald, but we concluded we knew how the CIA worked. They were pretty good. They would never employ such a person. Unless, as you say, it's's fiendishly cunning double bluff well here's the thing he's sent off to to minsk in belarus and he works in this electronics factory making radios and stuff and he works as a lathe operator now again if he's there as a spy what's he spying on soviet lathe technique i mean it's laughable so he's very miserable he spends the next year or so in minsk it obviously he dreamt that the grass was greener you know he thought this was the communist paradise and it turns out to be rubbish but also perhaps he thought that he would be
他是一个如此无能、笨拙的人。中情局永远不会雇佣这样的人。我的意思是，这是 20 世纪 90 年代档案公开后的克格勃的说法。他们说，我们调查了奥斯瓦尔德，但我们断定我们了解中情局的运作方式。他们相当不错。他们永远不会雇佣这样的人。除非，正如你所说，这是一个极其狡猾的双重虚张声势。嗯，这就是问题所在，他被送到了白俄罗斯的明斯克，他在这个电子工厂工作，制造收音机之类的东西，他是一名车床操作员。现在，如果他是作为间谍在那里，他在刺探什么？苏联的车床技术？我的意思是，这太可笑了。所以他非常痛苦，他在明斯克度过了接下来的一年左右。他显然梦想着草更绿，你知道，他以为这是共产主义天堂，结果却是一团糟。但也可能他以为他会
welcomed as uh of course he thought he he would go on this adventure and he would be a hero he would be somebody yeah and he's a nobody again i mean he's he's a nobody with no friends in minsk uh he writes to this u.s embassy and actually said and says i've changed my mind actually and the kgb intercept the letter interestingly and then they forget to send it this is your classic cock up rather than conspiracy the kgb intercepted the letter and forgot to forward it to the american embassy so So then he wrote again to the American embassy, why have you not answered my letter? I want to come home and all this. Now, just in the middle of all this, he meets a girl,
受到欢迎，作为……当然，他以为他会去冒险，他会成为英雄，他会成为“某个人”。是的，他又成了无名小卒。我的意思是，他在明斯克没有朋友。他写信给美国大使馆，实际上说，我改变主意了。有趣的是，克格勃拦截了这封信，然后他们忘了寄出去。这是典型的搞砸了，而不是阴谋。克格勃拦截了这封信，忘了转发给美国大使馆。所以他又写信给美国大使馆，为什么你们没有回复我的信？我想回家，诸如此类。现在，就在这一切之中，他遇到了一个女孩，
a pharmacology student called Marina Prusakova, who's from Archangel. She's only 19. Lee is still only 21. They're very young. They have a whirlwind romance, insofar as Lee Harvey Oswald is capable of a whirlwind romance, because he's not exactly the most glamorous and romantic character and after six weeks in april 1961 they get married and they have a very tempestuous relationship you astonish me the kgb are always their wiretaps because they're obviously spying on him the whole time they still don't trust him and the kgb wire
一个叫玛丽娜·普鲁萨科娃（Marina Prusakova）的药理学学生，她来自阿尔汉格尔斯克。她才 19 岁。李也才 21 岁。他们非常年轻。他们有一场旋风般的浪漫，就李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德有能力进行旋风般的浪漫而言，因为他并不是最迷人、最浪漫的角色。六周后，在 1961 年 4 月，他们结婚了，他们的关系非常动荡。你让我感到惊讶，克格勃总是监听他们，因为他们显然一直在监视他。他们仍然不信任他，而克格勃的窃听
taps find that they're always rowing and arguing and, you know, threatened to walk out and stuff. But their first child, June, is born in February 1962. And at this point, Oswald is still very, very keen on going home to the United States. The KGB have now totally looked into him, you know, because they wouldn't let him go if they thought there was any possibility that he was, you know for the cia or the fbi or whoever it might be the thing is what information could he possibly have well as you said kind of information on lathes in minsk yeah i mean there's nothing lathes production the kgb who are the world's most suspicious people
器发现他们一直在吵架，你知道，威胁要离开之类的。但他们的第一个孩子琼（June）出生于 1962 年 2 月。此时，奥斯瓦尔德仍然非常、非常渴望回到美国。克格勃现在已经彻底调查过他了，你知道，因为如果他们认为他有任何可能是中情局或联邦调查局或其他什么人的特工，他们就不会让他走。问题是，他可能有什么情报？嗯，正如你所说，关于明斯克车床的情报。是的，我的意思是，没什么，车床生产。克格勃是世界上最疑神疑鬼的人，
have decided okay this guy is just a complete freak and a loner let him go and marina as well is given permission yeah i mean they're happy to go too because marina is kind of a nobody marina is a 19 year old nobody she's not a dissident or anything no she's not a dissident she's not on anything they just think who cares let him go so may 62 oswald and marina go to the u.s embassy he reclaims his american, gets documents that allow her to come with him because she's his wife. The American embassy, this is a great thing for conspiracy theorists. The American embassy give him a loan to help his repatriation expenses of $435.
他们决定，好吧，这家伙只是一个彻头彻尾的怪胎和独行侠，让他走吧。玛丽娜也获得了许可。是的，我的意思是，他们也很高兴走，因为玛丽娜也是个无名小卒。玛丽娜是一个 19 岁的无名小卒，她不是异见人士什么的。不，她不是异见人士，她什么都不是。他们只是想，谁在乎呢，让他走吧。所以 1962 年 5 月，奥斯瓦尔德和玛丽娜去了美国大使馆，他收回了他的美国国籍，获得了允许她随行的文件，因为她是他的妻子。美国大使馆，这对阴谋论者来说是一件大事。美国大使馆给了他一笔 435 美元的贷款，以帮助他的遣返费用。
I mean, I don't know. Again, is it against the American law to renounce your citizenship and then? No. These things happen. You're a young man, early 20s. You've gone on a backpacking trip that's got totally out of hand. You go to your embassy and you say, please, can you help me back home? And the consular official gives you a severe withering look and says, did you not try to give up your citizenship two years ago? Have you not behaved in a ludicrous manner? Very well. Listen, don't do this again. Here's $400. Back you go. All right. But again, just to play devil's advocate, I mean, I suppose it's not on the same scale because the Islamic State committed terrible crimes,
我的意思是，我不知道。同样，放弃国籍然后……这违反美国法律吗？不。这些事情会发生。你是一个年轻人，20 多岁。你进行了一次完全失控的背包旅行。你去大使馆说，请帮我回家。领事官员会给你一个严厉、轻蔑的眼神，说，你两年前不是试图放弃国籍吗？你难道没有表现得荒谬吗？好吧。听着，别再这样做了。这是 400 美元。回去吧。好吧。但同样，只是为了唱反调，我的意思是，我想这规模不一样，因为伊斯兰国犯下了可怕的罪行，
but there were Americans who went to the Islamic State, gave up their American citizenship, and then kind of slightly repented of it and wished that it could go back. But Lee Hovild has not committed any crimes. It's not a crime to go to Russia. But they must be thinking maybe he's a spy. Well, obviously he comes to people's attention after he returns. So the FBI are interested in him because he's just come back from, he's a former Marine who has been in the Soviet Union.
但确实有美国人去了伊斯兰国，放弃了美国国籍，然后有点后悔，希望能够回去。但李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德没有犯下任何罪行。去俄罗斯不是犯罪。但他们一定在想，也许他是间谍。嗯，显然他在回来后引起了人们的注意。所以联邦调查局对他感兴趣，因为他刚从……他是一个曾在苏联待过的前海军陆战队员。
So they would not be doing their job if they didn't raise an eyebrow at him. But everybody who comes into contact with Oswald says, he's a loser, he's a fantasist, he's clearly not an enemy agent because he's so unreliable, so insubordinate, so difficult, he's not intelligent enough to be a useful gatherer of information. So people discount him and they just say, fine, let it... I mean, that's the attitude. It's so interesting that it's the attitude of both the Russians and the Americans. Oh God, let him go. And so they come back to the United States with their infant daughter, June. This is the middle of 1962. And Lee is looking forward to this exciting
所以如果他们不对他挑眉毛，那就是没尽到职责。但所有与奥斯瓦尔德接触的人都说，他是个失败者，是个幻想家，他显然不是敌方特工，因为他太不可靠、太不服从、太难相处，他不够聪明，无法成为有用的情报收集者。所以人们不理会他，只是说，好吧，让他……我的意思是，这就是态度。有趣的是，俄罗斯人和美国人竟然是这种态度。哦天哪，让他走吧。所以他们带着年幼的女儿琼回到了美国。这是 1962 年年中。李期待着这次令人兴奋的
reception when he'll be somebody and everyone will say what a tremendous person he's been on this great adventure and nobody cares and yet again he he's heading into obscurity okay so he comes back and when he returns to the united states he settles in the dallas fort worth area where his mother has moved to so we are the middle of 1962 and lee harvey oswald is now in dallas and when we come back we will look at the final stages of this grim story. We'll see you in a few minutes. Bye bye. reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
接待，他会成为“某个人”，每个人都会说他经历了一次多么伟大的冒险，是一个多么了不起的人，但没人关心。他又一次走向了默默无闻。好吧，他回来了，当他回到美国时，他在达拉斯-沃斯堡地区定居，他的母亲也搬到了那里。所以我们现在是 1962 年年中，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德现在在达拉斯。当我们回来时，我们将看看这个严峻故事的最后阶段。几分钟后见。再见。评论，一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are entering the final segment of this great epic sweep through the story of JSK and his murder. And Dominic, Lee Javios is now in situ in Dallas with his Russian wife Marina, their daughter June. What's going on? So we're in the middle of 1962. Lee, his great adventure to the Soviet Union has not worked out as he thought. He works as a sheet metal worker initially in the Dallas-Fort Worth area. He throws that job up pretty quickly, doesn't like it, leaves. He works in a photo print company as a trainee. He's fired from that for being insubordinate and difficult. He is now a very aggressive, sullen, troubled, and truculent young man. He's always getting into fights.
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在进入这个关于肯尼迪及其遇刺故事的宏大史诗的最后部分。多米尼克，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德现在在达拉斯，带着他的俄罗斯妻子玛丽娜和他们的女儿琼。发生了什么？所以我们现在是 1962 年年中。李，他去苏联的伟大冒险并没有像他想象的那样成功。他最初在达拉斯-沃斯堡地区做钣金工。他很快就放弃了那份工作，不喜欢它，离开了。他在一家照片印刷公司做实习生。他因为不服从和难以相处而被解雇。他现在是一个非常有攻击性、阴郁、令人烦恼且好斗的年轻人。他总是打架。
He beats his wife, who often has bruises and black eyes. He's still interested in his communism. He has not lost that faith. But his real passion, which I probably should have mentioned earlier, but his real passion is for Cuba. It is Cuba that he romanticizes. Tom, we know people have done that for decades afterwards. They romanticize Cuba, the Cuban revolution. They see it as exotic, as the underdog story. And does his fascination with Cuba succeed his fascination with Russia? Goes to Russia and it's all miserable and lathes and cold and whatever, empty supermarkets. And then he starts thinking of Cuba because it's romantic, and beards, and all that kind of thing.
他殴打他的妻子，她经常有淤青和黑眼圈。他仍然对他的共产主义感兴趣。他没有失去那种信仰。但他真正的热情，我可能应该早点提到，但他真正的热情是古巴。他浪漫化的是古巴。汤姆，我们知道几十年来人们一直这样做。他们浪漫化古巴，古巴革命。他们认为它充满异国情调，是弱者的故事。他对比古巴的迷恋是否取代了他对俄罗斯的迷恋？去了俄罗斯，结果一切都很悲惨，车床、寒冷、空荡荡的超市。然后他开始想到古巴，因为它是浪漫的，有胡子，诸如此类的事情。
Beards, exactly. I do wonder whether it's exactly that. He was obviously interested in Cuba from 1959 onwards when the Cuban Revolution happened. But Cuba looms so large in the American consciousness now. You've had the Bay of Pigs invasion. You've had the Cuban Missile Crisis. Fidel Castro is always in the news.
胡子，没错。我确实想知道是否正是如此。从 1959 年古巴革命发生起，他就显然对古巴感兴趣。但古巴现在在美国人的意识中占据了很大的位置。你经历了猪湾入侵。你经历了古巴导弹危机。菲德尔·卡斯特罗（Fidel Castro）总是出现在新闻中。
Cuba is lovely and warm, palm trees, rum. As you say, it's romantic guerrillas in combat fatigues. You can absolutely see why a troubled young man who has completely bought into the Marxist theory of history would romanticize Cuba. And who is still being dumped on by American capitalism. Yeah, because his life is still rubbish, actually. It still hasn't really worked out. We get into 1963. Here is what we know. Now, people have absolutely poured over the details of Oswald's life. But these are some of the things that we do know for sure. We know, I think, beyond any reasonable doubt that on the 12th of March, 1963, he bought this mail order rifle under a false name, A.J. Heidel. Now, why is Lee Harvey Oswald using a false name, you might say, if he's just an ordinary person and not a secret agent? It's because he hates authority. So almost instinctively, he doesn't want to give his real name. But also, he's a fantasist who thinks he's living in a world of espionage and dark deeds.
古巴可爱而温暖，棕榈树，朗姆酒。正如你所说，那是穿着战斗服的浪漫游击队。你绝对可以理解为什么一个完全接受了马克思主义历史理论的、陷入困境的年轻人会浪漫化古巴。而且他仍然被美国资本主义所压迫。是的，因为他的生活仍然很糟糕，实际上。它仍然没有真正成功。我们进入了 1963 年。这是我们所知道的。现在，人们绝对仔细研究了奥斯瓦尔德生活的细节。但这些是我们确实知道的一些事情。我们知道，我认为毫无疑问，1963 年 3 月 12 日，他以假名 A.J.海德尔（A.J. Hidell）购买了这支邮购步枪。现在，你可能会说，如果他只是一个普通人而不是秘密特工，为什么李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德要使用假名？这是因为他讨厌权威。所以几乎是本能地，他不想提供他的真实姓名。但同时，他也是一个幻想家，认为自己生活在一个充满间谍活动和黑暗勾当的世界里。
But presumably also, I mean, if he is thinking about actually using this gun on someone, then he wants to cover his tracks as well, right? Possibly. But I don't think he's thinking about using it on Kennedy because he can have no reasonable expectation that he and Kennedy will ever be in the same place at the same time. But doesn't he, before Kennedy, he tries to assassinate this guy, Major General Edwin Walker, who's a segregationist living in Dallas. Yeah.
但大概也是，我的意思是，如果他确实在考虑在某人身上使用这把枪，那么他也想掩盖自己的踪迹，对吧？可能。但我不认为他在考虑在肯尼迪身上使用它，因为他不可能合理地预期他和肯尼迪会同时出现在同一个地方。但在肯尼迪之前，他不是试图暗杀那个住在达拉斯的种族隔离主义者埃德温·沃克（Edwin Walker）少将吗？是的。
So do you think he gets the gun with that in mind? Could well do. Could well do, Tom. Edwin Walker. So we've said many times in this series about how in the early 1960s, there is this sort of seething, it's more than an undercurrent, it is a stream.
所以你认为他是在这种想法下才去弄到枪的吗？很有可能。很有可能，汤姆。埃德温·沃克。正如我们在本系列节目中多次提到的，20世纪60年代初，有一种暗流涌动，这不仅仅是暗流，而是一股洪流。
It is a babbling brook of discontent. It's not a babbling brook. Surely it's a turbid torrent. A turbid torrent. Very good. It's a turbid torrent. Yeah, babbling brook was totally wrong. Babbling brook is like, you know,
这是一条不满的潺潺小溪。不，这不是潺潺小溪。这肯定是一股浑浊的激流。一股浑浊的激流。说得好。这是一股浑浊的激流。是的，潺潺小溪完全用错了。潺潺小溪就像是，你知道，
when we do a podcast about poetry in Edwardian England. Wordsworth. But it's a turbid torrent of right-wing discontent and kind of conspiracy theories and stuff. And one of the people stirring this up is this guy, Major General Edwin Walker, who says, Kennedy is in bed with communists and black activists and all this stuff. He's very against civil rights.
当我们做一期关于爱德华时代英国诗歌的播客时。华兹华斯。但这股右翼不满情绪、各种阴谋论等等，是一股浑浊的激流。煽动这一切的人之一就是这位埃德温·沃克少将，他说，肯尼迪与共产主义者和黑人活动家同流合污，诸如此类。他非常反对民权运动。
And Oswald has clearly read up on him in all his kind of journals and decides he's going to kill him. Goes to his house in Dallas. He shoots Edwin Walker and the bullet hits the, it's the windowsill or something like that, or the window frame. He had left a note for Marina to say,
奥斯瓦尔德显然读过他所有的那些期刊，并决定要杀了他。他去了他在达拉斯的家。他向埃德温·沃克开枪，子弹击中了窗台之类的东西，或者是窗框。他给玛丽娜留了一张字条，说，
you know, goodbye. You'll probably never see me again. Thinking he would either be killed or he'll be arrested. But actually, he comes home very sheepish and kind of shamefaced because he's tried and failed to shoot Major General Edwin Walker. Now, if you believe this story, and there's no reason to doubt it whatsoever, then you have to accept that Lee Harvey Oswald is somebody who is already thinking about assassinating
你知道，再见。你可能再也见不到我了。他以为自己要么会被杀，要么会被捕。但实际上，他回家时显得非常局促不安，甚至有些羞愧，因为他试图射杀埃德温·沃克少将却失败了。现在，如果你相信这个故事，而且完全没有理由怀疑它，那么你就必须接受李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德是一个已经在考虑暗杀
public figures and is capable of taking the shot. And worth mentioning in that context that, of course, when he, on the 22nd of November, 1963, he takes off his wedding ring and he leaves all his money for Marina, doesn't he? Which he does. Yes, exactly right. Exactly right. The Edwin Walker thing hasn't worked out. Dominic, can I just ask you on the Edwin Walker thing? Presumably he doesn't get, I mean, nobody fingers him for this because otherwise he wouldn't. No. And actually Theo is asking exactly the same question.
公众人物并且有能力开枪的人。值得一提的是，当然，当他在1963年11月22日那天，他摘下了结婚戒指，把所有的钱都留给了玛丽娜，不是吗？他确实这么做了。是的，完全正确。完全正确。埃德温·沃克那件事没成。多米尼克，我能问一下关于埃德温·沃克的事吗？大概没人怀疑他，因为如果有人怀疑，他就不会……不。事实上，西奥问的也是同样的问题。
How could he try to shoot a member of the armed forces and try to get away with it? So it's at Walker's home. Walker is a former member of the armed forces and it's in the dark. It's at night. He shoots from an alley or something into the house, through the yard, and then he kind of scuttles off. So actually, how would you catch him? He's gone.
他怎么敢试图射杀一名武装部队成员并试图逃脱惩罚？所以那是在沃克的家里。沃克是武装部队的前成员，而且是在黑暗中。是在晚上。他从巷子里或什么地方向房子里开枪，穿过院子，然后他就溜走了。所以实际上，你怎么抓得住他？他已经跑了。
And he didn't kill him. So there's not a huge investigation into it or anything like that. So how do they know that he did it? He tells Marina. I think it's Marina who tells people that this is what Lee said he'd done. So anyway, he moves to New Orleans for a bit where he'd been born. He forms a local branch there of the Fair Play for Cuba Committee, which is a kind of left-wing, you know, let's stick up for Cuba kind of group. He's briefly arrested in New Orleans for scuffling with anti-Castro activists.
而且他没杀了他。所以并没有进行大规模的调查之类的。那他们是怎么知道是他干的？他告诉了玛丽娜。我想是玛丽娜告诉别人这是李说他做过的事。总之，他搬到了新奥尔良住了一段时间，那是他出生的地方。他在那里成立了一个“公平竞争古巴委员会”的当地分会，这是一种左翼的，你知道，支持古巴的那种组织。他在新奥尔良因与反卡斯特罗活动家发生争执而被短暂逮捕。
And then in September, there's this very peculiar incident when he takes a bus to Mexico City across the border border and he goes to the consulates of both Cuba and the USSR to try to get a visa for Cuba. Okay so you can't you can't just turn up in Cuba then? No you need a visa well you need a visa because how are you going to get there? Yeah how are you going to get there? No ferry. And actually everybody drags their feet it doesn't happen and eventually he gives up and he comes back home to Dallas. At that point, he has no connection whatsoever with the Texas Book Depository. But on the 14th of October, 12 days after his return to Dallas, so his wife has been
然后在九月，发生了一件非常奇怪的事情，他乘公共汽车跨越边境去了墨西哥城，他去了古巴和苏联的领事馆试图申请去古巴的签证。好吧，那你不能直接去古巴吗？不，你需要签证，好吧，你需要签证，因为你怎么去那里呢？是的，你怎么去那里？没有渡轮。事实上，每个人都拖拖拉拉，事情没成，最后他放弃了，回到了达拉斯的家。那时，他与德克萨斯州教科书仓库没有任何联系。但在10月14日，也就是他回到达拉斯12天后，他的妻子一直
in Irving living with this Quaker woman called Ruth Payne, rooming with her basically. And Ruth Payne says to Lee when he comes to call, oh, there's a job going at the book depository. Just taking school books to an elevator, basically. Not a very exciting job, but the kind of job that Lee could do. But also, Dom, just to say that if you see yourself as an intellectual, I mean, that must be very humiliating to be carting textbooks around. So maybe that's further incentivizing him with hostility to the system that has failed to recognize his talents and give him the opportunities that perhaps it should have done.
住在欧文，和一个叫露丝·佩恩的贵格会教徒住在一起，基本上是和她合租。李去拜访时，露丝·佩恩对他说，哦，教科书仓库有个职位空缺。基本上就是把教科书搬到电梯里。工作不是很令人兴奋，但却是李能做的那种工作。但是，多姆，我想说的是，如果你自认为是知识分子，那么搬运教科书一定是非常屈辱的。所以这可能进一步加剧了他对未能认可他才华并给予他应有机会的体制的敌意。
That's perfectly plausible, Tom. By that point, by the way, the FBI in Dallas are well aware of him. He has come to their attention. This is a source of great embarrassment to them after the assassination. They've actually gone and spoken to his wife, Marina, and to this couple of panes, the Quakers, about him and are kind of looking into him. But of course, they don't think he's any big threat. They don't take him terribly seriously. When he finds out they've been doing this and people have been asking questions, he becomes inflamed, furious. He hates the idea of the authorities checking up on him. But anyway, he's got this
这完全说得通，汤姆。顺便说一句，到那时，达拉斯的联邦调查局已经很了解他了。他已经引起了他们的注意。这在暗杀事件后让他们感到非常尴尬。他们实际上已经去和他的妻子玛丽娜以及那对佩恩夫妇，那些贵格会教徒，谈论过他，并且正在调查他。但当然，他们不认为他是什么大威胁。他们并没有太认真地对待他。当他发现他们一直在这样做，而且有人一直在问问题时，他变得愤怒、狂暴。他讨厌当局调查他的想法。但无论如何，他得到了这个
job at the books depository. And for the first few weeks, at least, it kind of goes okay. He hasn't yet been fired. On about the 7th and 8th of November, these are the dates, the Dallas papers start to announce that John F. Kennedy and his wife will come to the city. There is no way Lee Harvey Oswald could have known this before this point okay so everything before this point in a way is kind of irrelevant because up to this point there was no way that lee harvey oswald could ever expect to have an opportunity to kill kennedy so all this idea that the trip to mexico and the Gedwin Walker were all part of this long laid plan. That cannot be true because there was no way they could know that the stars would be aligned.
在教科书仓库的工作。至少在最初的几周里，一切似乎还算顺利。他还没有被解雇。大约在11月7日和8日，就是这些日期，达拉斯的报纸开始宣布约翰·F·肯尼迪和他的妻子将来到这座城市。李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德在这一点之前绝不可能知道这一点，好吧，所以在这之前的一切在某种程度上都是无关紧要的，因为直到这一点，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德绝不可能指望有机会杀死肯尼迪，所以所有关于去墨西哥和埃德温·沃克的事情都是这个长期计划的一部分的想法。那不可能是真的，因为他们不可能知道星象会排列在一起。
Yeah. It's entirely opportunistic. Entirely opportunistic. On the 15th of November. So that is what? Seven days before the assassination. The Dallas papers actually said there probably won't be a motorcade through the city but then four days later the dallas papers report there will be a motorcade and this is the route and the route is going to go
是的。这完全是机会主义的。完全是机会主义的。在11月15日。所以那是多少？暗杀前七天。达拉斯的报纸实际上说可能不会有车队穿过城市，但四天后，达拉斯的报纸报道说会有车队，这就是路线，路线将
past the depository that is the 19th of november and it is on that day that i think the idea must first have occurred to lee harvey oswald that the guy who is the personification of American capitalism, the personification of its policy towards Cuba, an enemy of revolution, a patrician, rich, handsome, successful, everything he despises, that this man will be driven right past the building in which he works in an open car at a very slow pace with the world looking on. Is it plausible that at that point, Lee Harvey Oswald thought, this is my chance to write my name into the history books and to have people doing podcasts about me in 2023? I think eminently plausible, Tom. Okay. Psychologically, it makes total sense. There is nothing in this story that
经过仓库，那是11月19日，就在那天，我想李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德一定第一次产生了这样的想法：那个作为美国资本主义化身、对古巴政策化身、革命敌人、贵族、富有、英俊、成功、他所鄙视的一切的男人，这个男人将以非常缓慢的速度坐着敞篷车经过他工作的建筑物，全世界都在看着。李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德在那一刻想到“这是我把名字写进历史书，并让人们在2023年为我做播客的机会”，这合理吗？我认为非常合理，汤姆。好的。从心理学上讲，这完全说得通。在这个故事中没有什么
I think would make you think, well, he wouldn't have done that. Well, that wouldn't have happened. I think it all fits. So could we just recap the circumstances in that story now that you've given us this brilliant psychological portrait of Lee Harvey Oswald and the account of his life, how that would then fit, basically what the evidence is that had led the Dallas police to conclude it's a cinch. So, I mean, I think there are something like 50 to 60 individual pieces of evidence that they compiled that led them, you know, created this jigsaw puzzle. And we can't go through all of those.
我认为会让你觉得，好吧，他不会那样做。好吧，那不会发生。我认为这一切都很吻合。既然你已经为我们提供了李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德精彩的心理画像和他的人生叙述，我们能否回顾一下那个故事中的情况，以及导致达拉斯警方得出结论说这很容易的证据是什么？所以，我想他们汇编了大约50到60条单独的证据，导致他们，你知道，拼凑出了这个拼图。我们无法一一列举。
We know that on the Thursday night, the night before the murder, he did something he had never done before, which is on a weeknight to go out to Irving to visit Marina and to collect a package, which he later described as curtain rods. Right. So this is the gun. Which is the gun. We know that the following day, Lee Harvey Oswald was at the Texas Book Depository that he arrived that morning we know that multiple witnesses saw what they thought was an assassin on the sixth floor of that building and we know that later on the police found a sniper's nest there and they found a gun now it's true people made competing claims
我们知道在周四晚上，谋杀案发生的前一天晚上，他做了一件他以前从未做过的事情，那就是在工作日的晚上开车去欧文看望玛丽娜并取一个包裹，他后来描述为窗帘杆。对。这就是枪。也就是那把枪。我们知道第二天，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德在德克萨斯州教科书仓库，他那天早上到了那里，我们知道多名目击者看到了他们认为是刺客的人在那栋楼的六楼，我们知道后来警察在那里发现了一个狙击手巢穴，他们发现了一把枪，现在确实有人提出了相互矛盾的说法
about men running on grassy knolls shots coming from different areas but there are a heck of a lot of witnesses who say they see somebody in the texas book depository and the fact of the murder weapon being found there and the fact that at least some if not most forensic experts say the shots did come from that direction and could have come from that direction, that suggests a reasonably plausible case. We know that Lee Harvey Oswald was the only employee of the Texas Book Depository who at any point said he'd been on the sixth floor. He contradicted himself in the interviews, but at one point he does put himself on the sixth floor. We also know, I think very revealingly, he's the only employee of the building who leaves the building.
关于有人在草丘上奔跑，子弹从不同区域射出，但有很多目击者说他们看到有人在德克萨斯州教科书仓库，而且在那里发现了谋杀武器的事实，以及至少一些（如果不是大多数）法医专家说子弹确实来自那个方向，并且可能来自那个方向的事实，这表明了一个相当合理的案例。我们知道李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德是德克萨斯州教科书仓库唯一在任何时候说他曾在六楼的员工。他在采访中自相矛盾，但在某个时刻他确实把自己放在了六楼。我们还知道，我认为非常有启发性的是，他是大楼里唯一离开大楼的员工。
Everybody else stays. He leaves immediately after the shooting. We know that he then behaves very weirdly. He gets on a bus. He waits on the bus. The bus is stuck in traffic. He then gets off the bus and gets a taxi, which is something that somebody with very little money, he never, ever, ever did. And then we know he goes
其他人都在。他在枪击事件后立即离开了。我们知道他的行为非常怪异。他上了一辆公共汽车。他在公共汽车上等。公共汽车被困在交通中。然后他下了公共汽车，打了一辆出租车，这对于一个几乎没有钱的人来说，他从来、从来、从来没有做过。然后我们知道他回家去拿他的左轮手枪。一名警察拦住了他，J.D.蒂皮特。他开枪打死了蒂皮特，这是无辜的人通常不会做的事情。我的意思是，如果今天下午一名警察拦住你，汤姆，我觉得你开枪打死他是不合理的。好吧，除非我假设刚刚暗杀了某人，希望我不会这样做。但只是想问，他的计划是什么？如果他射杀了肯尼迪并离开了教科书仓库，我的意思是，他要去哪里？他认为他要做什么？他为什么要拿左轮手枪？
home to get his revolver. A policeman kind of flags him down, J.D. Tippett. He shoots and kills Tippett, which is something that innocent people don't tend to do. I mean, if a policeman flags you down this afternoon, Tom, I find it implausible that you will shoot him. Well, unless I suppose just assassinated someone, which hopefully I won't have done. But just to ask, I mean, what's his plan? If he has shot Kennedy and he's leaving the book depository, I mean, where is he going? What does he think he's going to do? Why is he getting the revolver?
他拿左轮手枪是因为他认为今天下午可能会发生什么。也许他们会来找我。但你认为他打算去哪里？也许他打算回到墨西哥城，再尝试一次去古巴。对。好的。是的，这很合理。谁知道呢？
He's getting the revolver because he thinks something may happen this afternoon. Maybe they'll come for me. But where do you think he's planning to go? Perhaps he's going to go back to Mexico City, make another attempt to get to Cuba. Right. Okay. Yeah, that's plausible. Who knows?
我不认为他认为……有趣的是，我不认为他想不被认出来。所以这里有一种张力，不是吗？他某种程度上想被叫住。几乎所有的刺客都一定是这样。我的意思是，射杀罗纳德·里根的约翰·欣克利，1972年射杀乔治·华莱士的亚瑟·布雷默。当然，射杀约翰·列侬的马克·大卫·查普曼。射杀罗伯特·肯尼迪的萨汉·萨汉。
I don't think he thinks... The interesting thing is I don't think he wants to go unrecognized. So there is a kind of tension there, isn't there? He kind of wants to be called in a way. That must be the case with almost all assassins. I mean, the case with John Hinckley, who shot Ronald Reagan, with Arthur Bramer, who shot George Wallace in 1972. Mark David Chapman, who shot John Reagan, with Arthur Bramer, who shot George Wallace in 1972. Mark David Chapman, who shot John Lennon, of course. John Lennon, with Sahan Sahan, who shot Robert Kennedy.
我想在所有这些案例中，一定有一种想要被抓住的因素，因为你想让你的故事被讲述，我会说，因为无论如何，所有这些事件中都有太多的幻想和成为戏剧中角色的成分。回到奥斯瓦尔德身上，当他在电影院被捕时，他暴力拒捕并试图再次拔枪，对于一个无辜的人来说，这不太可能。当他被带进达拉斯警察总部时，他行了一个紧握拳头的礼，马克思主义者的敬礼，对于一个完全被诬告的人来说，这似乎也不太可能。同样不太可能的是他在审讯中表现出的冷漠、阴沉的态度，甚至开玩笑，不是开玩笑，而是说些随口的话，他说什么？我听说他们
There must be an element, I think, in all those cases of wanting to be caught because you want your story to be told, I would say, because there's such an element of fantasy and being the character in the drama about about all of these incidents anyway go back to oswald when he's arrested in the cinema the movie theater he violently resists arrest and tries to pull the gun again an unlikely thing for an innocent man to do when he's led into the dallas police headquarters he gives a clenched fist salute the salute of a marxist seems an unlikely thing again for somebody totally falsely accused to do as it similarly unlikely is his detached sullen demeanor under interrogation and indeed joke not joking but kind of making offhand remarks what's he say i hear they
因为谋杀而被处死之类的，如果你被诬告，你会那样做吗，汤姆？我希望永远不要发现。我希望永远不要发现。他在审讯中撒了谎，被诬告的人这样做非常罕见。他谎称去取窗帘杆，他谎称购买步枪，他谎称那张他拿着步枪的照片，我认为大多数专家认为，不是全部，但大多数专家认为那是完全真实的。最后，我认为对我来说，非常有说服力的是，他自己的妻子玛丽娜认为是他干的，当她来看他时，他的兄弟罗伯特也这么认为。他们都被他的态度震惊了，从一开始就非常担心
fry for murder or something like that would you do that tom if you were falsely accused i hope never to find out i hope never to find out he told lies under interrogation very rare for people who are falsely accused to do this he lied about fetching the curtain rods he lied about buying the rifle he lied about the photo of himself with the rifle which i think most experts think not all but most experts think is completely authentic finally i think for me, very persuasive, his own wife Marina thinks he did it when she comes to see him, as does his brother Robert. They are both shocked by his demeanor and extremely worried right from the beginning
因为他们认为他的表现就像他确实做过这件事一样。他的表现不像一个无辜的人，不像一个被陷害的人。最大的争论是他是否能在这么短的时间内发射这么多子弹。但他曾受过海军陆战队的训练，是一名神枪手。你提到过这一点。
because they think he is behaving as he would if he had done it. He is not behaving as he would if he was innocent, if he was framed. The big quibble is whether he could have fired so many shots in so short a time. But he's been trained as a Marine, as a sharpshooter. You said that.
他受过海军陆战队的训练，与电影《刺杀肯尼迪》中的场景相反，因为我最近才看到那个场景，凯文·科斯特纳和他的伙伴在六楼练习射击，他们只是说，这不可能做到，这不可能做到。
He has been trained as a Marine and contrary to what is the scene, because I only recently saw the scene in the film JFK, Kevin Costner is up on the sixth floor with his pal and they're practicing taking the shots, and they're just saying, it couldn't be done, it couldn't be done.
但它已经做到了。它已经被不同的神枪手多次复制，顺便说一句，他们不仅复制了，而且用类似的步枪改进了刺客的表现。另一个争论是关于所谓的“魔术子弹”。奥利弗·斯通的电影暗示子弹不可能穿过肯尼迪的喉咙进入约翰·康纳利的背部。同样，有许多专家说实际上它完全可以做到。康纳利并没有直接坐在肯尼迪前面。他稍微在他下面，六英寸
But it has been done. It has been duplicated many times by different marksmen, who have not merely duplicated, by the way, but improved on the assassin's performance with a similar rifle. The other quibble is about this so-called magic bullet. The Oliver Stone film suggests that the bullet could not have passed through Kennedy's throat and into John Connolly's back. Again, there are many experts who say actually it perfectly well could have done. Connolly was not sitting directly in front of Kennedy. He was slightly below him and six inches
向左，他转过身向人群挥手。所以这是可能的。还有关于肯尼迪的夹克被弄皱了，所以夹克上的弹孔之类的东西吗？我不记得了。是的，完全正确。问题是，对于任何此类犯罪，你都可以仔细研究每一个细节并发现不一致之处，因为历史和人类事务的本质就是如此，汤姆。对。那么问题是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德为什么要这样做？例如，我嘲笑了中央情报局这样做的想法，因为我不认为中央情报局在美国本土以这种方式行事是合理的。而且我不认为他们有明显的动机。李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德正是
to the left, and he had turned to wave to the crowds. So it is possible. And wasn't there something also about Kennedy's jacket gets bunched up, so the bullet hole through the jacket or something like that? I can't remember. Yes, exactly. The thing is that with any crime of this kind, you can pour over every detail and find inconsistencies because such is the nature of history and human affairs, Tom. Right. The question then is why did Lee Harvey Oswald do it? I have poured scorn on the idea that the CIA did it, for example, because I don't think it's plausible that the CIA acts in such a way on American soil. And I don't think they have an obvious motive. Lee Harvey Oswald is precisely
那种会以这种方式行事的人。他已经试图杀死另一个人。他杀了蒂皮特。他在电影院拔出了左轮手枪。他是一个暴力的人。你认为，我们一直在谈论他的怨恨感，他认为自己应该拥有被剥夺的社会地位的感觉，你认为肯尼迪如此出名、如此有魅力、如此英俊，他含着金汤匙出生，这是否让他成为一个更具吸引力的目标？哦，他确实是一个让我们所有人满意的目标，不是吗？我的意思是，听这个系列节目第一集的人可能会说，哦，他们对肯尼迪太宽容了，你知道，他们非常……因为我认为很多人对肯尼迪有一种自动的
the kind of person who does act this way. He's already tried to kill somebody else. And he killed Tippett. And he pulled his revolver in the movie theatre. He is a violent man. And do you think, again, we've been talking about his feelings of resentment, his feelings that he should have a status in society that he's been denied. Do you think the fact that Kennedy is so famously charismatic, so famously handsome, he's been born with this silver spoon in his mouth, maybe that makes him even more appealing as a target oh he's such a satisfying target for us all doesn't he i mean there would be people listening to the the first episodes of this series who would probably say oh they were very soft on kennedy you know they were very because i think a lot of people have an automatic
怨恨，因为他除了可怕的健康状况外，似乎命运给了他所有的祝福。他英俊。他富有。他有一个相对，我的意思是，他父亲和所有的女演员鬼混，但他有一个相当稳定的家庭。他聪明。但更糟糕的是什么？我的意思是，总是激怒人们的事情，他非常风趣。他非常优雅。你可以想象在哈佛，一定有很多人讨厌他，因为他似乎被命运宠坏了，拥有所有这些品质。李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，这一定让他发疯了。这方面的原型是赫罗斯特拉特，那个据说烧毁了以弗所阿耳忒弥斯神庙的希腊人，纯粹是为了被人们记住。你认为有这种成分吗？
resentment of kennedy because he's so apart from his horrendous health, it seems the fate has given him every blessing. He's handsome. He's rich. He has a relatively, I mean, his father's carrying on with all his actresses, but he has a fairly stable family. He's clever. But what's worse? I mean, the thing that always inflames people, he's very funny. He's very graceful. You can imagine at Harvard, there must have been so many people who hated him because he just seemed so spoiled by fate to have all these qualities. Lee Harvey Oswald, it must have driven him mad. The archetype of this is Herastratus, the Greek who burned down, supposedly, the Temple of Artemis at Ephesus, purely so that he would be remembered. Do you think there's an element of that?
是的。政治暗杀，总有一种模仿行为。李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德当然是第一个，然后很多人模仿他。但模仿他的人和他非常像。特拉维斯·比克尔，罗伯特·德尼罗在《出租车司机》中的那种原型，那些失败者，那些对事情违背自己意愿感到失望的人。他的个人资料，一直追溯到他十几岁时写的那些最初的个人资料，符合我们所知道的这些杀手的那种人。做这种事的人很可能是哈维·奥斯瓦尔德。如果你在寻找符合条件的人，他就是那个人。但即使不是，我认为仅就奥卡姆剃刀原则而言，即不要过度复杂化解决方案。最简单、最清晰的解决方案
Yeah. Political assassinations, there's always a copycat thing. The Lee Harvey Oswald one, of course, is the first, and then lots of people copy him. But the people who copy him are very like him. The Travis Bickle, Robert De Niro and taxi driver kind of archetype, people who are losers, who feel disappointed that things have gone against them. His profile, going right back to those first profiles that were written about him as a teenager, fits the kind of person that we know these killers are. People who do this are likely Javier Oswald. If you were looking for somebody to fit the profile, he would be the man. But even if it didn't, I think just on the principle of Occam's razor, that you don't overcomplicate solutions. That the simplest, clearest solution
很可能是正确的。它确实指向李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德。因为阴谋论使事情复杂化了，不是吗？确实如此。确实如此。人们因为这个原因而喜欢它。他们喜欢过度复杂化。他们喜欢相信自己掌握了别人没有的秘密知识。而且这种秘密知识不仅解释了这起犯罪，汤姆，因为如果这是中央情报局与黑手党合作完成的，这就解锁了所有的美国政治历史。因为你意识到实际上有一群阴暗的人一直在控制着这一切，而你知道这一点，你的邻居却不知道。所以情感上很满足。这就是为什么它如此令人着迷。这就是为什么有这么多电影，这么多
is likely to be the correct one. It really does point to Lee Harvey Oswald. Because conspiracies complicate things, don't they? They do. They do. And people love it for that reason. They love to overcomplicate. They love to believe that they are in possession of secret knowledge that other people don't have. And secret knowledge that not just explains this crime, Tom, because if this is done by the CIA working with the mafia, this unlocks all American political history. Because you realize that actually a shadowy group of people have been controlling the whole thing, and you know this, and your neighbor doesn't. So emotionally satisfying. That's why it fascinates so much. That's why there've been so many films, so many
电视节目，这么多小说。是的，但我认为它令人着迷还有另一个原因。肯尼迪遇刺事件发生时，正是60年代的乐观情绪即将转变的时刻。所以它是否对此有贡献，嗯，它显然对此有贡献，因为当然，在短短几年内发生了什么，这就是为什么我认为加里森案和吉姆·加里森对新奥尔良克莱·肖的调查，以及随后的暗杀书籍浪潮，但它们发生在1966、67、68年，我认为这并非巧合，它们发生在那个时候，因为那是美国陷入越南战争、民权运动的时刻。它已经被关于法律和秩序、骚乱等等的故事所取代。所以它有点像马尔科姆·X。
TV episodes, so many novels yeah but i think it fascinates for another reason as well the kennedy assassination happens at precisely the point when the the optimism of the 60s is just about to turn so whether it contributes to that well it obviously does contribute to it because of course what happens in just a few years and this is why i think the fact that the garrison case and the um the jim garrison investigation into clay shaw in new orleans and then the wave of assassination books but the fact they happen in 1966 67 68 i think it's no coincidence they happen then because that's the point at which america is engulfed in the vietnam war the civil rights movement. It has been overtaken by kind of stories about law and order and rioting and so on. So it's going a little bit Malcolm X.
是的。配乐现在是“大门”乐队，而不是，你知道，“海滩男孩”之类的。肯尼迪遇刺事件已经成为这种标点符号。这就是为什么它吸引了如此多的关注。还有人说，有许多小说中人们穿越时空阻止了暗杀。所以斯蒂芬·金写了一本。是的，是的。《11/22/63》。
Yes. And the soundtrack is now The Doors rather than, you know, The Beach Boys or whatever. And the Kennedy assassination has come to serve as this kind of punctuation point. That's why it attracts so much attention. And it's also said there have been a number of novels in which people time travel and stop the assassination. So Stephen King did one. Yes, yeah. 11, 22, 63.
那种非常奇怪的美国人组织日期的方式。向美国听众道歉，但这确实很奇怪。但这很糟糕。我的意思是，这应该是从中得出的结论。他们需要整理他们的日期系统。但在那本书里，我想肯尼迪获救了，结果1974年发生了核战争之类的，所以还有各种各样的其他书，那种认为它是关键转折点的感觉，当然事实并非如此，汤姆，因为如果肯尼迪活着，他会面临这个困境
That very weird American way that they organise their dates. Apologies to American listeners, but it is odd. But it is poor. I mean, that should be the takeaway from this. They need to sort their dating system out. But in that one, I think Kennedy's saved and then there's a nuclear war in 1974 or something as a result so and there's there's there are kind of various other ones as well that sense that it's the key turning point which of course it isn't though tom because had kennedy lived he would have faced this dilemma
在他的第二个任期内，关于是留在越南，实际上向越南投入更多军队，还是离开，无论哪种方式，他都会受到批评。他是否能以如此高的声誉离任似乎不太可能，但他能解决所有这些问题吗，民权、进入60年代末70年代初衰退的经济、所有这些事情、法律和秩序问题、对毒品和大学校园的焦虑以及所有这些东西。这个人的存在能解决这个问题吗？显然不能。显然不能。
in his second term about whether to stay in vietnam to actually commit more troops to vietnam or whether to leave either way he would have been criticized. Whether he would have left office with his reputation as high seems very unlikely, but would he have been able to fix all these problems, civil rights, the economy entering the downturn of the late 60s, early 70s, all of those things, the law and order issue, anxieties about drugs and college campuses and all that stuff. Would the presence of this one man have fixed that? Obviously not. Obviously not.
所以，多米尼克，你的意思是，在七集之后，它其实并不是很重要。不，我认为它非常重要，实际上。我认为这是因为它是一个耸人听闻的主题，而且有很多对它感兴趣的疯狂的人。学术历史学家倾向于回避它。出于完全可以理解的原因，他们不写关于它的书。但我认为肯尼迪阴谋论在民粹主义的兴起以及美国这种偏执的阴谋论政治中发挥了相当大的作用。所以深层政府的想法，任何挑战它的人都会被抹除的想法。有一个险恶的、阴暗的阴谋集团，一个与
So, Dominic, what you're saying is that after seven episodes, it wasn't really very important. No, I think it's hugely important, actually. I think it's because it's a sensational subject and a lot of bonkers people who are interested in it. Academic historians tend to fight shy of it. They don't write books about it for utterly understandable reasons. But I think the Kennedy conspiracy stuff has played a pretty big part in the rise of populism and in this kind of paranoid conspiracy theory politics that you have in America. So the idea of a deep state, the idea that anybody who challenges it will be kind of rubbed out. The idea that there's this sinister, shadowy cabal, an establishment cabal with links to
军工复合体、商业、有组织犯罪、政府机构有联系的建制派阴谋集团的想法。在过去10年左右的时间里，这已经越来越深入到美国政治主流中，不是吗？“匿名者Q”那一套。尽管正如你所说，如果有一个深层政府，你会认为它早就介入来解决问题了。完全正确，完全正确，完全正确。但随着我们明年接近下一次美国总统大选，会有很多人比以往任何时候都更积极、更热烈地谈论深层政府。所以遗产，我的意思是，即使没有肯尼迪遇刺，这也会发生。很多人比以往任何时候都更积极、更热烈地谈论深层政府。
the military industrial complex, to business, to organized crime, to government agencies. That, in the last 10 years or so so has become more and more embedded in the American political mainstream, hasn't it? The QAnon stuff. Despite the fact that, as you said, if there was a deep state, you think it would have stepped in by now to sort things out. Exactly, exactly, exactly. But as we approach the next American presidential election next year, there'll be lots of people talking about the deep state more vigorously and kind of fervently than ever. So the legacy, I mean, this would have happened even without the Kennedy assassination, Lots of people talking about the deep state more vigorously and kind of fervently than ever.
所以遗产，我的意思是，即使没有肯尼迪遇刺，这也会发生，正如我们在上一集所说的那样。这种民粹主义的偏执深深植根于美国政治传统中。但我认为肯尼迪阴谋论似乎将其推向了某种顶峰。好的。所以非常值得做七集节目。谢谢你，多米尼克。这绝对令人着迷。我，像每个人一样，对细节有一种模糊的感觉，但我真的、真的很享受有机会去了解
So the legacy, I mean, this would have happened even without the Kennedy assassination, as we said in the last episode. This kind of populist paranoia is deeply embedded in the American political tradition. But the Kennedy conspiracy stuff seemed to take it to its kind of apotheosis, I think. Okay. So well worth having done seven episodes on. And thank you, Dominic. It's been absolutely fascinating. I, like everyone, I kind of had a vague sense of the details, but I've really, really enjoyed the opportunity to get to grips
它，并掌握发生了什么的过程以及关于它的各种理论。所以非常感谢你引导我，并引导其他人了解这个非凡的故事。汤姆，你一直非常宽容，允许我做这么多关于它的节目。不，一点也不。我发现它完全令人着迷，我完全理解
with it and to kind of get on top of just the process of what happened and all the various theories about it. So thank you so much for guiding me and for guiding everyone else through this extraordinary story. Tom, you've been very tolerant in allowing me to do so much on it. No, not at all. I have found it completely fascinating and I entirely understand
为什么人们对它如此着迷。这是一个非凡的故事。好吧，你没有告诉人们的是，你自己也掉进了这个兔子洞，不是吗？因为你一直在看各种关于它的糟糕纪录片。
why people are obsessed by it. It is an extraordinary story. Well, what you're not telling people is that you yourself have fallen down this rabbit hole, haven't you? Because you've been watching all kinds of terrible documentaries about it.
我看了，但我很欣慰我没有被其中任何一部说服，因为首先，我已经沉浸在细节中
I have, but I'm reassured that I haven't been convinced by any of them because having, first of all, I'd kind of immersed myself in the details
关于实际发生了什么，所以我可以发现事情并不完全吻合的地方。西奥，我们已经看到了西奥认为是谁。西奥仍然认为
of what had actually happened and so I can kind of spot where things don't entirely fit. Theo, we've seen who Theo thinks it is. Theo still thinks
是林登·约翰逊。所以他是一个“草丘真相论者”。带着这个重磅炸弹，非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢你，多米尼克。我们会回来的。非常感谢。再见。再见。
it's LBJ. So he is a grassy knoll truther. And on that bombshell, thank you all very much for listening. Thank you, Dominic. And we will be back. Thanks very much. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦和我们的问答节目
I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。